à david poulin qui est le président du
syndicat allait constructif en étant
directeur avec lui bonsoir à vous david
poulin vous avez entendu aurélien véron
le conseiller a l'air à paris il faut
que les jets les jaunes se solidarise de
ces pme en souffrance aujourd'hui
de toute façon la plupart des petits
artisans sont des gilet jaune
on en voit beaucoup dans les cortèges
parce qu'ils n'y arrivent plus et ça
c'est quarante ans que notre pays tant
d'éclat
nos institutions sont à bout de souffle
la france est devenue une véritable
poudrière sociale et la déflagration
n'est plus très loin et qui mettra
certainement en danger nos propres
institutions
donc là on a un pouvoir qui n'entend pas
qui essaie de continuer une politique
qui ne fonctionne pas quand je dis un
pouvoir c'est pas forcément lié à la
majorité ne cesse la classe politique et
l'autre côté vous avez la france d'en
bas qui ne suit plus qu'il n'y arrive
plus l'invité précédemment disait que
c'était un problème qui ne comprenaient
pas parce qu'on les français touchés du
coup d'être social mais la plupart des
jeunes ne sont pas ceux qui se touchent
des aides sociales
les français demandent pas d être
socialement juste un futur et un avenir
quand ils ont un plan nous a promis de
travailler plus pour gagner plus
aujourd'hui on travaille plus pour
gagner moins
quand on est chef d'entreprise on n'y
arrive plus parce qu'on est assassiné
par les charges sur le bilan que vous
faites de cette rentrée d'aidé gilet
jaune
aujourd'hui il rentrait marqué on dit
c'est vrai par des violences dans et par
sens dans la capitale en fin de matinée
en milieu d'après midi hier tout
simplement il ya deux mille ans le
premier 6 cas comme une mobilisation
malgré la crise du commises et beaucoup
de gestes barrières qui ont été
respectées contrairement à ce qu'on
pouvait penser la seconde c4 toujours
ces violences que ce soit les jets joue
que ce soit les manifestations pour
défendre l'environnement les syndicats
ou les manifestations qui soutiennent
des clubs de foot on voit bien que
depuis quelques années les casseurs
infiltrés toutes les manifestations
possibles pour faire parler d'eux lors
leurs propres vidéos qui sont
certainement de fracasser notre pays et
ce pendant ce temps là on ne parle pas
du problème de fou le problème de fond
c'est un problème de pouvoir d'achat et
le futur de notre pays et de ce soir
toujours les mêmes revendications justes
pour conclure sur la gestion ces
territoires aujourd'hui de la
mobilisation
quel bilan vous faites le bilan est
simple c'est que face à une détresse
sociale
la réponse elle est sécuritaire et on
aimerait qui est notre répondeur je
voudrais juste faire une remarque sur le
grand débat où en sommes nous par
rapport aux grands débats on voit bien
que c'était une grande opération
d'enfumage et qu'aujourd'hui il n'en
reste plus rien donc au lieu de taper
sur les gens il va falloir un moment
permettre aux français de mieux vivre et
il ya des solutions qui existent et on
n'est toujours pas entendu et je crains
que la violence s'amplifie avec la crise
économique parce qu'il ya pas que des
gilet jaune on voit bien que sur le
terrain les français sont plus en plus
en colère et je suis très inquiet pour
l'avenir mon pays merci à vous d'aller
de poulain je rappelle que vous êtes
président du syndicat des constructif
merci à vous fin